magnus under pressure in the opening
that's my that's my big bet
the game has started but magnus carlsen
is not here he needs to switch on
hopefully he's back from that wedding
when uh they did that okay but we have a
decision
e4 e5 yes predicted yep and white's
night coming out this is standard stuff
black's knight defending central porn
and the italian game over the last few
years it's become a trend it's exploded
this type of opening and magnus is an
expert from the white side as well so
and uh even knife
oh okay so black's bishop retreating
that's rare and white's also slightly
ahead in development okay he does this
first he doesn't castle yet he pushes a
pawn in the center and wow this has made
magnus decide to bring his queen out at
an early stage this is extremely rare in
the italian opening to think that this
is necessarily too scary for eric he
does just castle his king and
finally black is starting to develop his
pieces you can even develop the white
knight okay he centralizes his rook
sensible stuff but it did take him a bit
of time and magnus if he keeps giving
those options to eric he'll be feeling
confident that enforce the kind of
control okay he's played it
and
magnus doing something which is actually
really popular these days and that's
just a copy agnes to maybe push his pawn
again a bit of copycat here all of the
rook spawn's now been pushed and that
has created a hiding place uh a few
questions that he brings his bishop out
first and
and it's one good sign actually for eric
is that he's actually taking these
decisions now quite quickly king is so
flexible does have the option of
castling it away tact at this early
stage normally with white you want a bit
of respect you occupy the center you've
done everything correct and your
opponent attacks you it's not too
pleasant but eric reacts instantly
potential attack will be less dangerous
so okay black recaptures i expect eric
to okay he has traded the bishops off
and he's brought his night out and here
we go the moves are coming almost
instantly now and uh this is because
both sides have clear plans to find the
best moves on every turn and okay he
does play this queen move back there
yeah he is killed
funniest moment in chess for me was when
vidit gujarati made an illegal move yeah
magnus ripping his shirt off that was
also fun too just a few months ago
actually okay okay making a bit of a
face there maybe he's surprised that the
game's become this complicated this soon
but meanwhile eric's made a decision and
that's to push a pawn forward that is
committal actually knights are the best
pieces on the outpost and that white
bishop in the centre of the board it
looks pretty but it doesn't really want
to ever move again if black can later
move the light squared bishop maybe
double up the two rooks against the
white king
okay
well we have a very direct answer here
because
magnus has simply moved the knight into
the beautiful outpost
the trouble yep so here you don't take
this pawn oh it hasn't happened um it's
like in football one side's running with
the ball down the right wing but the
other side put all their players on the
other side of the board and okay magnus
committing very quickly okay so knight
takes knight has been played now
yeah okay pawn takes knight is forced
yep but magnus once he gets back to the
board he will recapture it's slightly
surprising actually at least for me that
magnus didn't pre-move pawn takes knight
and so that even if he's not at the
board this move would have happened
automatically that's one of the pros of
online chess you can just uh make a move
okay did you just see that he was
wearing shorts yeah
that's magnus's style we've seen it
before
and okay he does eventually recapture
that knife black's bishop would use the
third row and the black rook would break
through towards the white king so yeah
too much power with this bishop and
that's why he does get rid of magnus
carlsen and um
yeah maybe
okay computer was just getting excited
because white did have some threats
okay but what about this pawn capture
that eric's just played king i mean
obviously you've got okay so he's
captured the pawn
and okay now knight takes pawn yeah i
don't think eric will contemplate going
to an end game firstly because he's
playing an endgame genius like magnus
carson but also because white's chances
lie in the middle game i was a little
bit distracted by the quiz of the day
answers if i'm honest
making me laugh center and actually
eliminate this black bishop and attack
against the black queen maybe his rook
takes rick
on then okay but he hasn't played it
this pawn is a big this pawn is a big
weakness rick takes rook on the board
suddenly i think we might see an upset
in this game you know okay
it looks so slow though
um yeah that must be what magnus is
banking on and actually eric he didn't
go in that direction with the white
queen he just stepped up one square
attacking black central pawn and pops
off in the middle there on the d4 square
it's just game over yeah okay you need
to keep that pawn alive and back down
that day banking everything on this pawn
okay 30 seconds
and the queen now centralizes herself
okay it just steps forward onto a dart
square that's sensible and there's no
immediate breakthrough he's got 32
seconds left and he's just relocated his
workhorse perhaps spring forward in the
right circumstance and give checkmate um
yes fans and he's doing that and
actually i just looked over that
position he was about to check mate
wesley so wesley resigning in this game
we've seen one move magnus occupying the
open line with his rook and
down onto the first row and that's just
going to be the end white's rook forced
it's a prisoner itself now next to the
white king and i think black can just
bring his rook into the game that's
pretty much it yeah i think he could be
one of the top grandmasters in the world
he's that talented and okay slightly
surprising by magnus not bringing his
rook down onto the first rank but this
looks good enough the bishop also trying
to support the white uh the black pawn
that from uh
helping it to promote and there we go
the black pawn did promote it became a
queen in the process white had to give
up a rook
for a bishop and upon and give some
annoying checks but uh where are you
going to put the queen to begin with so
you you've brushed it you've still got
to be very careful
we don't even have to answer eric he
does just give up
it was difficult it was lost but
yeah it was just that one move blunder
and he just gave up hope after that